[Musique]
c'est la fin idéale jatropha son journal
pour lire les nouvelles j'espère
qu'elles seront tous assurent elles
brian grant portable évasive à son cou
si les petites commérages l'autre petit
et qu'on de la forêt c'est l'intrus vrai
[Musique]
il y à toutes les informations à chaque
nouvelle édition on n'a jamais de
déception ça vous le découvrirez dans le
tue des cours de l'offre
[Musique]
[Rires]
voyons voyons quelles sont les nouvelles
d'aujourd'hui aux madmoizelles de la
cigogne engagé un bon à tout faire un
bon à tout faire mais oui mais oui il y
avait des bonnes à tout faire maintenant
il ya aussi des bonds à tout faire il
faut de tout pour faire un monde
n'est-ce pas surtout les fans alors bon
bras vous en êtes vous eh bien voyez
j'ai les idées la cuisine tirer les
parquets astiquer les meubles best
seller da et maintenant agir et vite me
reposer dix types d je sais que je suis
fatigué mademoiselle et oui notre bon à
tout faire commence à regretter d'avoir
accepté de travailler chez la cigogne
mais comme je le connais il va chercher
un moyen de se libérer au
alors vous ne venez pas travailler à la
la la la je ne sais pas mais je me sens
en lançant vous vous sentez quoi
maintenant très mal celui pas vrai ou
jouer la comédie pour ne pas travailler
on vous avez sûrement raison bezeau le
lion je suis pas homo excusez moi madame
la guenon noah une gonnot mais quelle
horreur et notre mii la cigogne à la
demander de l'aide aux frères castor est
vraiment très bon vous êtes madame
mademoiselle et magma vers la baleine
puis pas du tout il faut pas le
contrarier un surtout on n'attend pas
une baleine mais oui mais oui je suis
une balle est la grosse baleine une
grosse balle
l'énorme baleine une énorme balle est
pour sa part d'un bal un faux les
madmoizelles de la cigogne conduisit
notre malade chez tosca la tortue qui
avait quelques connaissances médicales
alors alors ce principe a attrapé une
phlébite aiguë
c'est grave mais comment at-il attrapé
cette maladie à microbes qui s'appelle
la flemme c'est contagieux
si on reste à ne rien faire alors je
doive agitée en travaillant une autre
cigogne pour ne pas attraper de phlébite
aiguë se mit à faire tout le travail
qu'elle avait ordonné à zip qui
confortablement allongé soluce dorloter
or je suis ici mais il faut vous reposer
monsieur là le ton il n'en est pas
question je ne veux pas rater votre
limite aiguë il ne faut pas que j'arrête
de travailler
avérés dont mademoiselle la guêpe le
travail c'est la santé
l'incident n y fit mine de partir mais
se cacher derrière un arbre et
l'écoutent et tu en feras je ne peux
quand même pas rester toute ma vie
coucher salle est pas jouer les grands
malades
je commence à m'ennuyer tant pis pour
toi ça t'apprendra est bel et bien ce
que vous avez vous vous sentez mal
contre et mme mazel de la cigogne
il y des zips à une cigale excusez moi
monsieur nous sommes à fayet elle a
attrapé une phlébite aiguë il faut vous
coucher tout de suite mais il ya encore
beaucoup de travail à faire mentionner
les fonds vous inquiétez pas je vais le
faire à notre place c'est guéri
maintenant si grippe a
les choses sont rentrées dans l'ordre
moi aussi je sais jouer la comédie
hyper devenu mon propre à tout faire et
moi je suis devenu une grande malade j 9
les mythes aiguilles quel bonheur et oui
les sons sont rentrées dans l'ordre
mademoiselle de la cigogne se fait
servir par zip lelièvre qui sert de bon
à tout faire bientôt cherté les femmes
nous irons ensemble une nouvelle édition
du petit écho de la forêt
[Musique]